this ape does not exist neither does
this one this one this this this or this
in fact i've created all of them using
an ai that i trained myself and today
i'm going to show you how it's done and
what other cool things you can do with
this hi there my name is yannick welcome
to the channel today i'm going to walk
you through how i built the gan ft ai
and how you can use it it's all
available online so you know if you want
go check it out
this video is sponsored by bright data
use my link to sign up to them and get
25 dollars in free credits and they'll
match your first deposit up to 250.
thanks bright data for sponsoring this
video i'll tell you more about them in
just a second nfts have obviously been
super popular and these board apes are
the pinnacle of it and do you know what
power we have with our ai we are going
to be rich we're going to give you an
ape and then another ape and another one
like if these are apes we'll be like you
get an ape and you get an ape and you
get an ape and eight apes just all the
way
sponge sponge everything's fungible now
needless to say once it's done we're
gonna be ending up with a model and i'll
just put it out there you can go to the
model every time you click submit you'll
get a new instance of some creation of
that model it's not perfect but it's
pretty good but given that this is an ai
model we can actually do more than just
generate new ape for example take a look
at this ape that was generated by my
model and this ape that was generated by
my model what we can do is we can look
at what the model things are all the
in-between apes between the two this is
generally called an interpolation it's
pretty cool to explore what the model
learns and how it sees the world now
needless to say i'm not the first person
that does this nor is my model the best
model there have been people who have
investigated this much more and have put
more work into it and i'm not going to
be able to mention all of them right
here but nathan cooper jones has a very
cool medium article on his
investigations on the board ape
collection and gans and so has serial
sucka on twitter so the technique we're
going to use today to make our ai is
called a generative adversarial network
a gan which is the same methodology that
powers websites like this person does
not exist dot com where every time you
refresh you get a new artificially
generated face but there's more there is
this sneaker does not exist dot com this
chair does not exist dot com and pretty
much anything you can think of so gans
generative adversarial networks were
first invented in uh
um
well let's not talk about that right now
they were first mentioned in a 2014
paper by ian goodfellow and
collaborators called generative
adversarial nets and oh boy in recent
years they have made progress so these
were from the original paper you can see
you can barely make out a face it's okay
at generating digits but anything else
is way out of scope and they're just a
couple of years later as you can see
right here these things have gone insane
the pictures they produce are almost
impeccable they're very versatile and
they're at the forefront of computer
generated imagery very briefly a gan
consists of two neural networks one
called the generator and one called the
discriminator and while the generator
tries to produce these fake images the
discriminator tries to differentiate
those fake images from real images from
a dataset now as the discriminator gets
better at discerning what is real and
what is fake the generator in turn gets
better at fooling the discriminator and
therefore both neural networks get
better and better and better and at the
end the generator is really good as you
can see right here so the first thing
we're going to need is data in fact what
we're going to do is we're going to go
to openc and we're going to collect the
board apes yacht club of that website
the board api club is a nft collection
on openc it consists of 10 000 of these
apes each one of the ape comes with its
own attributes and properties as you can
see they are procedurally generated but
only certain combinations exist and
certain attributes are much more rare
than others now they do have an api but
i don't trust apis i want to get the
data directly from the website and
that's what we're going to use bright
data for bright data offers scalable
robust collection of public web data as
a service this is really really cool and
can save you a lot of troubles they
really have everything you need in order
to collect data for example they
maintain a vast network of proxies all
over the world and from any kind of
device so you're really not limited in
what you can collect though at the heart
of their service is definitely the data
collection engine they have various
levels of difficulties of how you can
interact with them naturally since i'm a
nerd i'm gonna go for the programming
layer which is the lowest layer but it's
also the most fun layer so here's my
scraper for open seas board a yacht club
so let me show you what i did so the
code on top here simply says that i want
to use a proxy in the us and i want to
go to the board ape yacht club website
then i want to wait until the navigation
action has completed so essentially i've
arrived at the website now it turns out
that openc is actually one of the more
difficult websites to scrape because
it's very very dynamic like watch what
happens when i reload the page the page
already loads but then the items load
individually moreover if i scroll down
you can see that constantly new apes are
being added instead of these
placeholders this is called an infinite
scroll even though i guess it's not
infinite but it means that you can't
just load the website once and you have
all the apes available you need to do so
in a stepwise fashion so yes it's going
to be a bit more tricky than just
loading up the website and scraping the
content but hey that's what we're here
for nothing that a little bit of kodi
kodi magic can't solve so we've got to
instruct our scraper that it waits for
you know just a bit more after it has
arrived at the website now the code
you're seeing here is mostly javascript
but bright data has introduced a bunch
of utility functions like this navigate
thing up here or the wait function here
which we're going to use right now so
we're going to wait for the grid to
initially become available which means
that the first set of apes has been
loaded we're then going to call the
parse function right here and the parse
function is one of the main functions of
data collection essentially it goes to
the website and collects some data from
it as it is you can see down here what
we are selecting and if your css foo is
good you'll realize that we're going for
this counter here this counter tells us
how many total apes there are and why is
that important for scraping well you see
if you open a bunch of them you can see
that the different urls here all have an
ending that is different but then a
prefix that is the same so my suspicion
was that they're probably numbered from
0 to 99999 and we could just iterate
through all of them in order to get them
and yes i was right so all we have to do
then is loop from 1 to whatever that
number of total grid cells is and call
the next stage every bright data scraper
is divided into stages and you could
probably already guess that the second
stage deals with collecting an
individual ape now that's a lot easier
than before all we do is we navigate to
the url we wait for the summary to be
ready we wait for the history panel to
be ready and then we call parse now as
you can see we are collecting quite a
bit more data than before so i do not
only want the image of the ape i also
want its attributes and i want the price
of when it was last sold which i'm going
to get from this table right here see
whenever it says sale that's when the
ape was sold 78 ether
to garyvee all right well you do you and
while we're not going to use the
attributes or price today it is valuable
data for our future endeavors all right
so once i have my scraper all i got to
do is go to the scraper say initiate and
off it goes starting and collecting now
that we have the data the next thing we
need is some code and i could write it
myself however i'm not in the mood to do
so so i'm going to go over to nvidia and
get the official implementation for
stalgan 2 ada which already has
excellent code available on github not
only do they have code they have a very
thorough readme that describes how you
can use their code how you train your
own stuff so after converting the images
using their data set tool essentially
it's just a matter of calling train dot
pi i know i wish machine learning was
more interesting but this is it so off
went my first training run you can see
that the loss of the discriminator
starts up high goes down low and then
starts rising again i don't know is that
good is that bad while the generator's
loss starts slow goes high and then
drops down well gan training is one of
these things where the metrics are a bit
like tea leaf reading and there's not
too much indication that you can go by
of whether your model does something
well or not one of the metrics that is
sometimes useful is the fid and as you
can see right here the fid of my model
quickly dropped down which is good low
fid is good but then quickly went up
again after only a few hundred steps so
that concerned me and then i looked at
the output data so the code base will
actually sample every couple of hundred
steps a new batch of images so that you
can see what progress your model makes
at the very beginning it's just noisy
gibberish as you can see right here but
very quickly it gets the idea of what it
should do approximately this already
looks quite promising but then as it
went on you can see that what is this
why is everything turned to the side now
to this day i don't really know
why this is turned to the side i suspect
it's part of the data augmentation that
sometimes turns images to the side
although i haven't looked that that's
the case so clearly this was a failure
and a collapse i had to start again i
tweaked the hyper parameters a little
bit and then a second run went much much
better yeah this is the last step and it
got like a bit different but in a weird
way so off i go starting again so the
second run i changed some hyper
parameters around i did some tweaky
tweaky kodi kodi you know like us
machine learners do and very quickly
that model became better you can see
already that the diversity is higher
from the beginning and after only a few
steps we got something really neat going
you can see it still makes a lot of
mistakes there are a lot of artifacts in
here however it's clearly going into the
correct direction in fact remember that
fid metric that i've showed you before
well the orange line here is the one of
the new model so you can see as the blue
one gets worse again the orange one just
continues to drop this is really good
really nice it goes down it goes towards
zero down further and further now i have
no comparison because there's not a lot
of academic effort into producing board
apes so i have no clue how good nine is
but i like the shape of the graph and
that's important so as you can see by
step 9000 or so the model was getting
pretty decent and i was hopeful but i
just wanted to see what happens when i
let it train for longer and in hindsight
i shouldn't i mean check out when i zoom
out
ouch but you know this is normal every
gan will collapse at some point and in
fact the checkpoints that i've put
online for my project which you can also
download are definitely from the regions
where it hasn't collapsed yet now i've
done a few more runs where i managed to
get it training for even longer before
it collapsed such as the green or the
red one right here but all of these
things will give quite satisfying
results so i was happy so what are the
results this is a hugging phase space
i've uploaded my model there and you can
go to it you can click on the button and
every time you click you get a new
produced ape this ape is produced in
this instant the same ape has never been
produced before and will never be
produced after so this is fully yours
and it's absolutely fungible i'm not
gonna mint these things as nfts or
anything like this just download it you
can definitely produce more than one
image for example if you set it to three
it'll give you a grid of three images
and if you click the interpolate check
mark it will do the generate two images
and then generate everything in between
you see very funny now because this is
not the full experience of fungibility
i've also made a little website so this
is why culture.com apes if you go to
this there's nothing different every
time you refresh you get a new ape in
fact it calls the same api however if
you click download right here
oh well you're just gonna have to try it
for yourself and here's another fun
thing that you can do with this this is
a little application that i call what's
your app and what you can do is you can
go here
you can input a little image of whatever
you want right here doesn't have to be
me but you know it better be me and it
will generate the ape that corresponds
to your picture the most now this is
really fun i've only put 250 steps i'd
usually put a thousand steps then the
quality is a bit higher it doesn't
always work you sometimes have to retry
but if you do retry you get different
apes and it's quite fun you get a little
video of how the ai searches through the
latent space in order to match your
picture the technology behind this that
i had to add is open ai's clip model
clip is trained on text image pairs and
therefore understands what's inside an
image much better than for example a
classic imagenet trained resnet by using
clip and back propagating into the game
i'm able to search the latent space of
again in order for a picture that is as
similar as possible in the eyes of the
clip model to the picture that i input
what my app does is it tries to match
how clip sees the image you have input
and how clip sees the image that is
output from the gan i've used a very
similar technique to generate my music
video so go check that out for a more
in-depth explanation and the same
technique has powered a lot of recent ai
art for example dali 2 by openai if you
search on twitter for the hashtag dali
you can get some amazing outputs of this
model nadali doesn't use again but it
also uses clip as a central part of its
architecture now due to this being quite
heavy in compute i cannot exactly put
this on hogging face space that'll just
take too long you actually need a local
gpu and some time a thousand step take
roughly two minutes or so but if you can
give it a try again it doesn't always
work but it's fun when it does and here
are some more cool results that i got
with it
[Laughter]
all right this was it for today's video
thank you so much for being here let me
know if you like project report kind of
style videos like this i've put all the
code and checkpoints and whatever online
i've put links to everything i mentioned
in the description please go check it
out thank you so much again to
brightdata for sponsoring this video
it's really cool to have them on board
in a second i'm just gonna show you a
couple more things you can do with them
just in case you're interested they have
a really established infrastructure for
collecting public data and the
possibilities of what you can do with it
are almost endless people use this for
example to verify that the ads that they
make online really reach their target
audience by scraping from the
perspective of their target audience
this is a really cool idea i would have
never thought of this another example is
you can go out there to e-commerce
websites collect pricing data aggregate
this from all over the web and either
let this influence your pricing or offer
your customers a better deal i mean so
many things are possible with cool web
scraping technology and if you can do
this at scale regularly and
automatically that is mighty mighty
powerful now i've given a shot at
collecting some other data by myself i'm
going to show you that now so stay tuned
and i wish you the best again many
thanks to today's sponsor bright data
now let me show you a little bit what
more you can do with their platform i've
gone by far the most difficult and the
most cumbersome route to use their
platform in the project today it is
usually much easier which you're gonna
see right now so if i go to their
platform and i go to collectors i add a
new collector and there are all kinds of
collectors already pre-defined all the
big social media companies all the
e-commerce companies amazon and ebay all
the hotel pages and everything already
has pre-defined collectors for you so
many of the things that you would
possibly want to scrape will already
have a scraper defined all you need to
go is enter a few details and off you go
for example here i can scrape myself a
data set of instagram posts that have
the hashtag ai art now people upload
these pictures whenever they make some
art with ai and they want to show it to
the world and i just want to download it
all so with bright data super easy i
simply go to the collector that's made
for scraping hashtag on instagram i
enter ai art i say how many posts i want
off i go again a neat json file at the
end with everything that i'd want to
know about these posts or here what if i
have some new business idea like airbnb
for campsites i might want to research a
lot about which campsites are in which
area how expensive are they how occupied
are they and so on so i might want to
regularly scrape all of the campgrounds
around certain regions no problem in
fact bright data has a scraper for you
already prepared for that too simply
select the scraper enter the locations
you'd like to know about and off you go
you can set these scrapers to run
manually or on a schedule and then
export the data to wherever you want
into your cloud they can send it to you
as an email you can download them
yourself whatever you like so not only
do they have predefined scrapers they've
actually let their scrapers run on a lot
of public-facing websites and scraped
all public data from those for example
you can see there are a lot of data sets
available one of them is this linkedin
company data set so this is a registry
of over 50 million companies and all the
publicly available data that's on
linkedin now whether you're a recruiter
or looking for a new job or looking to
sell something to businesses this data
is really valuable now this is only a
small set of features that bright data
offers they just make collecting data
from the internet a whole lot easier so
thanks again so much to brightdata for
sponsoring this video please check them
out there's a link in the description
i'm very sure you'll be pleasantly
surprised with that i'll see you around
bye